[Music]
this is a court of law the standards of
evidence are completely different the
court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth i think it's about time to accept
the existence of the devil
i'm here to tell our story there's not
one day
in my life that goes by that i never
think about it
it's always there it scars you i met
arnie when i was
working down in bridgeport when arnie
and i rented a home
my brother david he started getting
physically attacked
where arnie comes into play arnie
witnessed what they
assumed was a demonic possession with
david
david was suffering so bad and we're all
right there with them
arnie couldn't take it anymore because
he was trying to help my brother
clean him alone
at his wit's end he called out to nadine
and invited him into his own
and when he had challenged the beast
it gradually started to manifest and
come to him
february 16 1981 my blessed
started to really become inebriated
your girl's gonna think i'm a drunk
arnie said let's get out of here
i started walking down the stairs and i
heard a guttural yell out of arnie
and then i turned around looked at my
boss he's on the ground and i seen blood
all on his shirt
i think i hurt someone
the newspaper came and i told him what
happened i said
he was possessed i want the truth to be
told
that these things are real
something terrible happened here
you cannot take this lightly
good versus evil it's real
hey you okay there
jesus i think i hurt someone
this is ed warren here with lorraine all
right let's get started
residents of brookfield were shocked
this afternoon by the broad daylight
murder of bruno saul
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness
swears to tell the truth
i think it's about time they accept the
existence of the devil
whatever was going on whatever happened
that day that was morning
it's a witch's totem we think your
family was cursed
and that connection is still open
i'm only interested in reality
but i can see things that your people
can't
[Music]
uh
something terrible happened here
a master satanist is not an adversary to
be taken lightly
she's doing it
lorraine you need again come back you're
saving him with everything you have
because that's what my ferry will cost
all right
[Music]
you